sous un soleil estival l'église de
jésus-christ des saints des derniers
jours non officiel des mormons ouvre les
portes de son premier temple en france
la congrégation compte déjà une centaine
l'église mormone dans l'hexagone nous
attendons ce moment depuis longtemps
les membres de l'église ici en france
ils ont l'occasion d'aller au temple à
madrid une loi en suisse mais finalement
nous avons ensemble vraiment ici aux
chaînés cinq ans de travaux auront été
nécessaires pour construire ce site de
9000 m² comprenant le temple accessible
aux seuls mormons et un grand jardin
ouvert au public
selon la mairie du chesnay le chantier
aurait coûté 80 millions d'euros environ
entièrement financée par l'église
mormone ce site nous a plu dès le début
parce que c'est un endroit très calme
c'est un endroit paisible je crois que
les ville du chesnay et les villes de
versailles sont des villes extrêmement
calme paisible pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient découvrir ce culte et
l'édifice sera ouvert au public pendant
trois semaines du 22 avril au 13 mai de
9h à 21h
c'est un très bel édifice ou non ce sont
quelque part isolé du monde
nous y venons tous vêtus de blanc pour
un moment de prière et de méditation
dans un lieu hautement spirituel pour
les autorités mormone ce premier temple
en france n'a pas vocation à attirer de
nouveaux fidèles
il devrait toutefois faciliter la vie
des trente huit mille mormons de france
qui devaient jusque là se rendre dans un
temple en suisse pour se faire baptiser
ou se marier